la république n'est pas une idée
abstraite
tous les jours elle s'incarne dans les
femmes et les hommes qui emporte les
idéaux et qui agissent pour l'intérêt
général et notre république marche à cet
égard sur plusieurs voies d'abord la
sphère politique
elle est formée de tous les
représentants de la nation de tous ceux
qui ont reçu mandat du peuple et qui
sont ici présents et que je salue
ils ont refus pour porter l'intérêt
général dans les instances électives et
cette sphère va de l'état jusqu'aux
communes qui sont sur nos territoires
les premiers interlocuteurs des
françaises et des français et les plus
sûres relais de leurs préoccupations et
je salue à ce titre tout
particulièrement la mer et le conseil de
paris qui sont présents parmi vous
aujourd'hui comme le veut la tradition
et plus largement tous les élus ici
présents dont je sais la rigueur et la
détermination à remplir le mandat qui
leur a été confiée mais c'est aussi ce
qu'on appelle la société civile
notre république a d'ailleurs toujours
penchons pensée voulu la représentation
de la société civile à côté de la
représentation politique comme si la
nation c'est d'évidence n'étaient pas
épuisées par la seule représentation
politique et parfaitement synthétisé
c'est l'esprit des constituants de 1958
lorsqu'il crée le conseil économique et
social et c'est toute l'importance
accordée par notre philosophie proli
politique et notre pratique de chaque
jour ce qu'on appelle souvent les corps
intermédiaires
il s'agit dans notre société notre
économie
les organisations syndicales et des
organisations patronales dont je salue
également ce soir les représentants
ils ont un rôle essentiel à eux aussi
dans la manière dont notre société est
structurée à côté des territoires
représentés par nos élus il structure
la vie de la société la vie productive
les rapports au sein de celle ci et ce
fut d'ailleurs tout l'esprit du texte de
loi portée en fin d'année dernière qui a
conduit à repréciser les rôles
respectifs des uns et des autres à
remettre les représentants politiques au
bon endroit celui qui consiste à faire
la loi et définir les normes pour toute
la nation et à reconnaître pleinement
leur rôle l'action des organisations
syndicales et patronales c'est-à-dire de
construire à partir des préoccupations
du terrain à partir des réalités
économiques et sociales de la branche de
l'entreprise déséquilibre les plus
pertinents nous avons à travers les
réformes des derniers mois rck l'arrêt
fier les règles et les modes de
financement des réformes à venir
continueront en cette direction qui je
crois ont permis de redonner une clarté
plus contemporaine à la relation entre
cette société politique
mais cette société civile a redonné
aussi les conditions d'un consensus
construit au plus près du terrain des
rapports économiques et sociaux à
permettre de construire la règle au bon
endroit a déployé partout la loi où elle
est utile partout le contrat où il se
justifie